Sadokist: Aim punch significant, hen1 not peaking spots it right away!
That is the ScreaM we know. He's gonna pull this back and...
Semmler: ...just obliterate him. Easy.
Anders & Semmler: Woah!
Casters: What!
Anders: ScreaM! Is this real?
There's almost no topping it.
Deman: He's going to pop up trying to go for that jumping shot and he lands it! On device.
Takes down the headshot. Jump in mid air from ScreaM.
Who else would land that headshot? Xyp9x now, in a real tricky position
bomb planted. It's in his favour but there's two people lining up the shots
and ScreaM finds another head.
James: ...happen in this round? nV fighting straight back with their buy.
oh double peak looking so good oh my god ScreaM! great thanks for taking some
Sadokist: ...site before the rotations come in GuardiaN gets RPK that's their last
hope toward long. And it's ScreaM on a fast rotate that's able to at least get one now two.
But, bomb's already planted it's ScreaM again, he's going to get another!
It's just him left though..
because seized has found Ex6TenZ but we know ScreaM can do this. HenryG: ohh
that four headshots and he's in the position.
HenryG: He's done it!
Sadokist: ...there's nothing they can do.
what a round from ScreaM.
DDK: Does it matter James? Is it going to be like that flank from before?
uh ScreaM's going to be able to take two quick entries there but he's alone.
Completely alone but he'll take another kill
as he tries to clutch this. One more - oh my god ScreaM!
Semmler: He's there with that pop flash it's going to be so sick it goes off but they are
in the correct angle to deal with it still
wins the duel versus snacks. But, VP continue to press
forward onto the B site. ScreaM holding the line, ScreaM with the triple headshot
just stopping them cold. Brings it back to a
two on two and he could get the ace! He's doing the damage and he opens it up for maikelele.
Machine: ...has got a bit of a chest infection and
can barely breathe
so that's why we are sometimes
burning up but in the meantime I got
better battery found food it could very
well be a very very aggressive and
Armando and Susie be not fucking friends
and me go have the limelight and 316
fact this is the man you cannot
challenge like this every time I thought
the watching here's your things like
that go down lower jump and basically
yeah that stuff with the stuff the great
place and its registry places that
oh my god speaking of dreams he has come
back with a vengeance bring some
punishment back yeah oh and of course
and Smith is always mr. just so shocked
always upset come from early on they did
play they wanted to working that passive
style but now you can see strength of
character for extreme doing that respect
for protect up at the age little bit
messy is the CT close three flights on
straight to one another in a bit of
damage to each other they come in with a
vacay because their faces what we always
evenly between our play date way you
know